it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we reveal the stories
behind the headlines and for that we go
to fox news contributor raymond arroyo
raymond as we've been reporting biden
unveiled
his big climate initiatives today
yeah but it wasn't only about climate
regulations laura it was about
jobs today is climate day at the white
house
and which means that today is
jobs day at the white house they're not
going to lose jobs in these areas going
to
create jobs they're going to get
prevailing wage to
cap those over a million wells these
aren't pie in the sky dreams
these are concrete actionable solutions
and we know how to do this
the obama biden administration reduced
the auto industry
or rescued the auto industry and helped
them retool
laura he was right the first time the
obama biden administration did reduce
the auto industry they spent 23 billion
dollars
on a united auto workers union bailout
if you'll remember
this was a sweetheart taxpayer-funded
deal to shield their union friends
from taking pay cuts during the auto
bankruptcies period but the biggest joke
of today was
that banning of new gas and oil leases
is going to create more
jobs he says well they can close those
abandoned wells
under biden's plan there'll be many many
more abandoned whales
this is like me saying my policies are
going to create tons of
going out of business sign makers laura
that's not good
this is the way to ask but wait a second
raymond i remember
back in the radio days tracking
biden's promises about green jobs i
think it was what 2009
more green jobs means more money in your
pocket at the end of the month
yeah but the money landed in somebody
else's pocket laura it wasn't the
taxpayers
obama and biden promised 5 million green
jobs as part of that 787 billion dollar
stimulus package
the only thing green was the piles of
cash spent on this boondoggle
they never hit their goal and remember
they counted janitors
cleaners and bus drivers as green jobs
this was a boondoggle from start to
finish including solyndra which you
mentioned
well when when they go back and they
keep saying well
it'll all be soldered solar has so many
great jobs well i'm sure there'll be
some jobs
but what's going to stop the solar panel
manufacturers without trump's
tariffs and other trade protections in
place
for moving over to asia whether it's
china or vietnam or india
they're all going to move overseas so
we're going to be left with no oil and
gas jobs
and no solar panel job so i guess you're
right well lauren it was china that put
solyndra out of business remember that
it really is the job of the media though
to hold these politicians accountable
and call out errors
which is why it is astounding that after
years of ruthlessly fact-checking trump
the washington post has announced
they're backing off a biden and
discontinuing
their presidential lie tracker laura
glenn kessler tweets
we have no plans to start a biden false
or misleading claims tracker
just as we had no plans at this point to
start a trump tracker
the constant tweeting of falsehoods
forced our hand but
we will have an open mind if the need
arises and we'll consider one
but wait wait a second raymond jim
acosta over at cnn
he believes the fact checkers should not
be
packed away just yet we need to devote
in our news organizations uh some
resources to fact checking
uh these fringe ideas that are going to
continue to exist
on the far right in this country this is
not a time to uh to put away our fact
checkers in some sort of you know
uh box on the shelf uh they're they're
going to be needed to fact check this
movement that
you know is not going away trump may be
going away trumpism is not
so it's the movement he reveals himself
the bad man at mar-a-lago he needs to be
fact-checked
not the guy spending billions or
executive
uh you know issuing executive orders
like their candy at halloween i've never
seen anything like it but fear not laura
the los angeles times is stepping into
the gap they have launched a new project
called covering kamala harris which they
say is a beat dedicated to her
historic rise to the white house or at
least the naval observatory i guess they
don't realize the vice president doesn't
live at the white house
but maybe they know something we don't
know laura who knows well raymond let's
look at
some of the penetrating coverage and it
is pretty tough from the la times this
is from their
instagram account okay
it's just a reposting of harris's own
social media propaganda
with absolutely no comment right right
since when is hugging a spouse news you
know though
there are some important reports here
laura here's one how kamala harris's
decision to join a sorority
helped her become vice president and my
favorite my grandmother
was named kamala so is my vice president
why that matters this is like the in
style magazine or teen beat
for the political class laura never seen
anything like this
yeah this is the tiger beat of politics
and poor old jim acosta
chimacross is like well trump's gone
trump's gone but trump-ism
isn't he's does he not understand that
he's just
proving to everyone that he's an
ideologue
on the left who hates populist
conservatives okay then be a pundit
don't stand up there with your tie on
and pretend to be some
you know objective journalist you just
look like a fool okay
i mean right or left these politicians
need to be held accountable by the media
that's our job